good morning I'm Martin
and the director of the beam viene en
thank you for coming to the culture and
crisis the international conference
hosted by the VNA with our colleagues at
the Institute for preservation of
cultural heritage at the Yale University
and with the support of UNESCO and if I
may say that when I called Jeff and
Simone who has this very important job
to build a security department at the
Yale University I think it took less
than two seconds he said yes they do it
and thank you to all of you for coming
today let me make it very short where
because we have not so much time today
we have a lot of short statements and I
think it's extremely important that with
me today I witness a very few things
about what who and why let's start with
the VNA the VNA was founded as an
international institution international
museum today will probably say a museum
of globalization mid 19th century if you
want to learn about India mid 19th
century it was in the VNA if you want to
learn about the Middle East it was in
the VNA go to our collection you will
make expeditions in that country in
those countries and cultures and
civilizations at that time and today
it's an amazing heritage if you if your
parents are from Aleppo Damascus and you
grow up in London anyone to see
something about your hometown come to
the VNA and by the way today our team
around Anna Jackson installed beautiful
showcase in the chair Mill gallery with
our objects from Syria just in case F
time to see it so there's a reason a
real reason for us to think about what's
going on in Syria to support our
colleagues if we can and to understand
what's going on so information
information and information is something
that is probably the most important
right now share information to share
information that only among the serums
the museum's has somehow
I don't know where it comes from but
museums have this big ego and I think if
we learn to share more information among
the museums across the sector but also
with trade our trade with military with
NGOs with help organizations Foreign
Office's they would help a lot just
collect information if I'd be really
brutal to you today I don't have too
many expectations for a real outcome
today but just the fact that you are
here today is so important there's
another way and it's a very personal y
and this very personal i talked to you
already its Vernon bravely runnin who is
the security director of the VNA needs
the former head of Scotland Yard's
specialist at an antique unit I asked
one in years ago to start this program
and we are still in the beginning but
running greater than network of museums
a kind of museum security group and i
hope you will endure we will support
Ronan's strategies for the future so the
meeting today is part of it who will be
here today we are really glad that you
accepted our invitation it's the second
time from hey so it's a second time that
I called the Italian ambassador mr.
ambassador and you said immediately yes
we will try it the first time it was the
prime minister mr. NC who came and now
it's the deputy secretary of culture and
tourism thank you for coming to the
conference secretary because I think
it's so important that you tell us more
about your press release about two weeks
ago when you said we need some join
forces with military
n culture I think it's a very
interesting topic we have colleagues
from the British Museum and the
Smithsonian Museum we have the Foreign
Office of Germany and the FCO we have I
grown man alchemist and we have a series
of videos presentation from colleagues
in Yemen Libya Nigeria Molly and Syria
if there is something that I just talked
to martin bailey about it because if we
think about the why we have that
conference today and what is it exactly
would be really difficult to agree that
are just some breast cuttings of the
last few days so i think there's a lot
of reason if you just open youtube the
newspaper TV or whatever it is and then
you know why we are meeting today I
think we all feel pretty desperate I
think we all share that feeling that we
are without power and if we can share
ideas today bring different ideas
together in the evening and you have
something like a list of action points I
think that it could be the most
prominent task for today thank you so
much for joining us thank you for being
here and have a great conference